you're in this awkward position of being
an increasingly more and more important
part of the Marvel world but as as agent
Jimmy Wu but you're also in the DC world
and that must be very complicated
because you've got I don't know how you
can inhabit Both Worlds Without fans
attacking you do you know what I mean
you're like uh you're like you're in a
blue state but you're wearing a mega hat
uh yeah you know a good Environmental
Policy but well you know I don't believe
in uh it helps vaccinate it it helps to
not be on social media that that helps
uh but uh yeah I don't know how it
happened it just I I kind of book those
two jobs at the exact same time and it
just kind of somehow magically happened
you know because I remember I think on
the same day even like hey you got this
Marvel thing and hey you got this DC
thing like in a couple hours later and I
was like how well do I have to pick one
and you know my reps were like well
let's see if we can make them both work
and then I don't think they told anybody
because I think I think Marvel people uh
the people making uh Marvel movies are
probably so snobby about DC they won't
even watch it and the DC people are like
I'm not watching that oh [ __ ] and so the
Aquaman people aren't watching you know
they don't know that I think they don't
know if it's possible but they're I mean
they you know unless they're like my
parents and my career that they're
they're about no your whole career have
been about deception and that's what's
happening right now is you're living a
double life you're inhabiting both of
these comic universes that's like a
modern day equivalent of being a union
Scout
you're gonna get roughed up in an alley
I know it's like on the waterfront
you know it's so funny because I was
watching I loved one Division and when
you show up when agent Jimmy Wu shows up
in that I'm watching I was watching it
with my son yeah he was so excited when
you showed up it's cool you hit us so
cool
the fan loyalty and
um he's very Discerning about things he
likes and doesn't like and so there's
this connection to you now like oh great
oh great I'm glad that he's in this unit
I'm glad yeah no that's very sweet yeah
that's very sweet yeah I mean it's it's
it's
it's it's cool also because I'm not a
superhero I'm just like a regular guy
and I uh and some say it that's the
greatest superhero of all who says that
absolutely nobody yeah I don't know no
but I I think it's I mean actually in a
in a world inhabited by people that can
float shoot beams out of their eyes walk
through walls yeah um you know there's
constant portals opening up and they're
jumping through being a guy in a suit
yeah it makes you pop you're a guy in a
suit who's got a job to do you're a
civil servant and it's got its own cool
factor to it yeah I I saw a friend
showed me something online uh someone
had like tweeted something about like oh
my God it's there's this like quick
scene where I'm like bringing coffee to
to uh to um some of my uh partners and
they were like oh my God it's we love
that he's bringing coffee to his you
know his co-workers
and I'm like yeah you know that is like
something that should be cool yeah you
know right because also I think if
you're watching uh any of the especially
the later Avengers where there's
constantly different holes opening up in
the sky and Dragons made out of fire are
coming out and Thor's punching
Spider-Man and I I thought you were
gonna say like like the Hulk brought
coffee no but if you saw the Hulk say
hulk go
get latte anyone else want hot drink I
think everyone would stop for a second
when they're spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars on these CGI
effects and if there's just a moment
where a Hulk say you know or he doesn't
even ask he comes back oh that would be
yeah and he says uh to Captain America
me see you drink
a green tea once Bayou green tea wow
Hulk me not sure green cause everything
looked green to me yeah it's not
actually green tea it's it's actually
coffee you look green to me don't make
Hulk man
let me also buy you green cookies
you green everyone green everyone green
LensCrafters
okay tell us what you see oh green okay
take it easy okay
every day
see Patty's Day again I hope just want
beer
we've been through this